hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
hepatitis b the added value of an
accurate diagnosis
for the optimization of the patient's
clinical management
i'm susie valdez of labs and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by dia soren
to learn more visit them at diasoren.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at
any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
click on the support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or report your
problem
by clicking at the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i now present today's speaker dr
valentina
zieger an associate professor of
virology at the department of
experimental medicine at the university
of rome
torvigata italy for a complete biography
of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr zieger you may now begin your
presentation
welcome thank you so much
it's a great pleasure for me to discuss
today
this topic this important topic with you
considering
a worldwide population of the 7 billion
individuals 2 billion have been infected
with hbv among them
250 million have developed
a chronic infection furthermore
it has been estimated that every year
around 1 million hbv chronically
infected
patients die to the end-stage liver
diseases
such as cirrhosis or heptacellular
carcinoma
these numbers highlight the huge burden
of hbv
infection worldwide of course
the geographic distribution of a chronic
hbv
infection varies reaching the highest
prevalence in western pacific regions or
in africa particularly in sub-saharan
africa in africa hbv
is the major cause of death among
viral hepatitis what about
europe according to the last ecdc
estimates the rate of a chronic hbv
infection tended to remain stable
over time particularly during the last
decade and notably the highest
rate of a chronic hbv infection
was observed in a young adult
particularly aged
from 25 up to 45
years however all these
numbers these prevalences are considered
just the tip of the iceberg indeed
there's a large underestimation in the
real
prevalence of a chronic hbv infection
and this is mainly due to the limited
intervention strategies aim at
hbv screening and diagnosis
but why is expanding access to hbv
screening and diagnosis
important it is important since hbv
plays a crucial pathogenetic role
indeed hbv is considered
an important carcinogen being
responsible for around
50 percent of the cases of
liver cancer in regions
endemic for hbv infection
it has been estimated that around
70 80 percent of hcc
cases can be attributed to
hbv indeed the risk
to develop hepatocellular carcinoma
is 25 fold higher
in patients with a chronic hbv infection
than in general population and notably
the risk to develop liver cancer
still persists in individuals with
resolved hbv infection
and disease mainly due to the
persistence of
hbv dna in the liver
of infected individuals
despite the clinical resolution of the
infection we know that liver
inflammation
plays a pivotal role in the onset of
liver cancer
indeed the persistent activation of
cytotoxicity lymphocytes can
favor repeated cycles of
cell death and cell regeneration
these repeated cycles can promote
genome instability thus increasing the
risk
for the neoplastic transformation of the
hepatocytes
however unlike the other ethiologies
hbv-related hepatocellular carcinoma
can develop also in young adults
ends in complete absence of liver
inflammation
so in complete absence of any signs
of liver fibrosis or cirrhosis
and this is due to the fact that hbv
is characterized by direct
pro oncogenic properties first of all
hbv can integrate portion of its dna
into the hepatocytes genome and
this event of hbv dna integration
can favor for instance the upper
regulation of
oncogenes the loss of onco-suppressors
or can favor genome instability
indeed this concept is in line with this
recent study
presented at the digital international
liver
congress promoted by easel
showing that hbv dna integration
can act as a bridge for
inter-chromosomal translocation
these inter-chromosomal translocation
can promote genome instability
and as we have said before this can
increase the risk
for the neoplastic transformation of the
hepatocytes
secondly hbv genome encodes
the so-called hbx protein
this protein is crucial for viral gene
expression
however when it is produced at very high
levels it can induce
it can favor the expression of
genes involved in cell proliferation
or it can inactivate p53
thus contributing again today and
increase the risk
for the neoplastic transformation of the
cell
thirdly the genetic variability in hbscg
can
modulate hbv on quadrantic potential
indeed previous studies have shown that
the accumulation
of deletions or stop carbons in hbscg
can determine the production of aberrant
or truncated the forms of hbsag
that are retained that accumulate
inside the diaphotocytes thus promoting
an oxidative stress and in turn increase
the rate
of cell proliferation
based on these findings
a full suppression of a viral
replication by an early and a potent
antiviral treatment is so far
the only weapon we have to slow down
the progression towards cirrhosis
and towards hepatocellular carcinoma
in this light a proper hbv screening
and diagnosis is crucial for a timely
identification
of patients who are at the risk of
disease progression
and those who need to start an antiviral
treatment
we know that the hbsag is the all mark
for hbv diagnosis we all know very well
that the positivity to hbsag
indicates active viral replication
and that the positivity for more than
six months
indicates the establishment of a chronic
infection
however beyond the qualitative detection
so far we have a number of assays
allowing the quantification of the hbsag
and hbsag quantification
plays an important role for a proper
staging
of a chronic hbv infection for
predicting the risk to develop liver
cancer
and for monitoring treatment response
let's talk about the first two points
we know that chronic hbv infection
is a highly dynamic phenomenon
composed by different phases
each phase derives from a delicate
equilibrium
between the extent of viral replication
and the strength of immune response
in particular the first phase of a
chronic hbv
infection is defined h-b-e-a-g
positive chronic infection this
phase is characterized by
elevated viral replication partially
controlled or minimally controlled by
the immune system indeed in this phase
serum hbv dna so viremia
is very very high and the transaminase
transaminases
are normal as soon as
an efficient immune response is
mounted we have the entry into the
so-called
h-b-e-a-g-positive chronic
hepatitis characterized by a
decrease in serum hbv dna
and flares in transaminases
in this phase we have an increase the
risk
for liver inflammation so and increase
the risk
for cirrhosis and also for the
hepatocellular carcinoma
if the immune system prevails
on the virus we have the entry
into the hbeag negative
chronic infection characterized by
low serum hbv dna usually
less than 2 000 international unit
per ml and normal transaminases
in this phase the risk of disease
progression
is low not absent but very low
however there's a fraction of
individuals
losing the favorable status of
hbeag negative chronic infection
indeed this fraction of individuals
enters in the so-called h-b-e-a-g
negative chronic hepatitis characterized
by periodic elevations in a serum hbv
dna accompanied by flares
in transaminases followed by
remission periods characterized by
low serum hbv dna and normal
transaminases a crucial diagnostic
objective in clinical practice is to
differentiate
between hbeag negative
infection and the remission phase
of hbeg negative hepatitis
indeed these two phases patients in
these two phases
are both hb eag negative
have a low serum hbv dna less than 2 000
international units per ml have
persistently normal transaminases and a
comparable
intrapathic reservoir however these two
groups of patients
have a completely different rate of
disease progression
so which is the parameter that can help
us
in discriminating between these two
groups of patients
this parameter is represented by
hbsag quantification indeed
the study shows that in patients
with hbeag negativity
low serum hbv dna and normal
transaminases
and hbscg less than 1 000
international unit per ml can help
predicting the status of the hbeag
negative infection
with a very high diagnostic accuracy
and a very high negative and positive
predicted value these results
are in line with these studies from
an asian group showing that the
combination
of low serum hbv dna
low hbsig and the normal transaminases
can help identify the patients
with the minimal risk of disease
progression
a completely different scenario is
observed in patients
with hbsag higher than 1000
international units per ml indeed
the study shows that in hbeag negative
patients
with the low serum hbv dna and the
normal transaminases
having an hbsag higher than 1000
international unit per ml correlates
with an
increase the risk to develop liver
cancer
at this regard i would like to share
with you this
clinical case of a young man
coming from west africa with the chronic
hvac infection at our hospital
this patient received a diagnosis of
hepatocellular carcinoma a single large
nodule in complete absence of
fibrosis the patient died two months
after receiving
the diagnosis of liver cancer
the biological characterization of this
patient
showed that the patient was hbeag
negative
he had the serum hbv dna law
only 700 the international unit per ml
and the normal transaminases and in line
with the previous study
quantitative hbsag was higher than
1000 international unit per ml
furthermore the sequencing of hbv genome
revealed the presence of hbv
genotype e we know that
so far 10 hbv genotypes have
been identified genotype e
circulates with a higher frequency
in west africa and furthermore
and notably this genotype has been
associated with
a faster progression towards liver
cancer
than genotype d and a
so overall finding support the role of
quantitative hbseg
for a proper staging of a chronic hbv
infection and to predict the risk of
hepatocellular carcinoma
in the setting of hbeag negativity
furthermore overall findings support the
importance to
integrate biological parameters for a
full characterization
of hbv pathogenetic potential
let's talk about the role of hbsag
quantitative hbseg
in monitoring treatment response
we know so far there are two classes of
anti-hbv trucks interferon alpha
and reverse transcriptase inhibitors
also called milk let's talk about
interferon alpha we know that interferon
alpha
has the potential to reduce and to
suppress
viral gene expression does a favor in
the establishment
of the hbea negative a chronic
infection and also the achievement of
hbsag loss hbsag loss is an
important marker since it indicates the
achievement of
hbv functional cure
however these important endpoints are
achieved in clinical practice
in a small proportion of
patients and this highlights the
importance of the biological parameters
that can help predicting biological
response
to this drug one of these
parameters is represented by hbv
genotype
we know that different hbv genotypes
have a different
rate of response to interferon alpha
the best virological response is
observed in genotype a
conversely the worst biological response
is observed in genotype d and
has recently shown also in genotype
e another important parameter
for monitoring the response to
interferon
alpha is quantitative hbsag
indeed has shown in the easel guidelines
and
in several studies the kinetics
of hbscg declines during
treatment with interferon alpha
have helped to define the so-called
stopping rule to interferon
and us to identify patients who need to
stop
who need to suspend interferon alpha
since they have a very limited
probability
for a successful response
what about nuke we know so far
that nuke in particular in techavir and
tenofovir
can efficiently suppress the activity
of the reverse transcriptase enzyme
does suppressing the production of
major and infectious viral particles
this is translated in clinical practice
in the achievement of biological
suppression
in the vast majority of the treated
patients furthermore dump
suppressing the production of viral
particles
can dampen liver inflammation and this
can
lead to the regression of fibrosis
and cirrhosis and can also lead
to a reduced risk to develop
liver cancer the risk is reduced
even if it is not completely abrogated
what about hbsag levels
during treatment in
hbeag negative patients
hbsag levels tend to remain
stable during treatment or to undergo
minimal decreases a completely different
scenario is observed in the setting of
hbehg positivity indeed
in hbeag positive patients
we observe the higher declines
in hbsag compared to
hbeag negative patients and in
particular
an hbsag decline higher than one log
during the first year of a treatment
can help identifying those patients
with a higher probability to achieve
hbscg loss and thus with a higher
probability
to achieve hbv functional
cure so these findings support
the role of quantitative hbsag in
predicting biological response to
treatment with
interferon alpha and in the setting of
hbeag positivity quantitative hbsag
can help identifying the
the group of patients more prone to
achieve
hbsag loss
but there are there are factors
that can affect hbscg
detection and quantification
a factor can be represented by
hbsag genetic variability
particularly in a region that is defined
as major hydrophilic region
this is a major hydrophilic region of
hbscg
is the target of neutralizing
antibodies but it is also the target of
antibodies used by the majority
of the says for hbssg
detection and quantification
so far around 20
scape mutations all localized in the
major hydrophilic region
have been identified notably
these mutations can alter
can hamper hbscg recognition
by neutralizing antibodies including
those
induced by the vaccine and also by
diagnostic antibodies thus affecting the
proper
hbsag detection and quantification
which is the prevalence the circulation
of these immune escape mutations
we have analyzed a large data set
composed of more than 900
patients infected with hbv
genotype d and we have found
that around 18 percent of the patients
are burst viral strains with at least
one immune escape mutation
and notably the presence of these immune
escape
mutations particularly when combined
correlates with hbsag
negativity so with a negative result
despite ongoing viral replication
and thus despite detectable serum
hbv dna does the supporting the role of
these mutations
in hampering the proper hbsag
recognition what about
immunoscape mutations in other hbv
genotypes some immune escape
mutations detected in genotype d
can be constitutively found in other
hbv genotypes this means that
an amino acid associated with an immune
escape
phenotype in genotype d can be the world
type
amino acid in another genotype
as shown in this interesting study
this can lead to differences in
antigenicity profiles among
hbv genotypes so this means that
this can lead to differences in hbscg
recognition
by neutralizing antibodies and also by
diagnostic antibodies and of course
faster studies are necessary to better
elucidate this important point
from a pathogenetic and diagnostic point
of view a clinical setting in which
immune escape
mutations play a pivotal role
is represented by immune
suppression-driven hbv
reactivation immune suppression-driven
hbv reactivation
is defined as an abrupt increase in
serum hpv dna
in patients with a chronic hbv infection
or an abrupt reuptake an abrupt
reappearance
of hbv dna in patients with
resolved hbv infection again
we should remember that in patients with
the result with hbv
infection we have the persistence of hbv
dna
whose transcriptional activity is
tightly controlled by
the immune system due to the
ever increasingly use of immune
suppressive
agents hbv reactivation can
so far occur in a large variety of
clinical settings and if not properly
managed and treated it can lead to
severe
forms of hepatitis including feminine
hepatitis
that can lead to patients death
different studies including one from our
group
has shown that there's a fraction of the
patients
with hbv reactivation
who are hbsag negative despite
hbv reactivation and so despite
ongoing viral replication and elevated
levels of the serum hbv dna
the analysis of hbsag
sequences reveal the presence of a
peculiar type of immune scape
mutations in particular the analysis of
hbsag sequences
reveal the enrichment of mutations
associated with the acquisition of the
so-called
additional and link glycosylation
sites it is an nn-link glycosylation
site
a an in-link glycosylation site is a
signal motif
composed by only three amino acids
that is responsible for the attachment
for the binding of a carbohydrate
shield this carbohydrate shield
can mask the epitope surface
does a hampering altering the proper
hbsag recognition by neutralizing
antibodies
but also by diagnostic antibodies
and this can explain the hbsag
negative result observing patients
with hbv reactivation
so based on these findings it is
important the use of innovative essays
for hbsag detection and
quantification targeting hbsag
regions hbsag domains other than
the major hydrophilic one
this is the case for instance of daily
eisen
murex sa based on the use
of different monoclonal antibodies
targeting multiple epitopes
throughout the hbsag protein
and this is feasible thanks to the use
of a specific
agent allowing the detachment of hbsag
from viral envelope followed by
its denaturation the denaturation is a
crucial step
allowing the exposure of new epitopes
we have quantified a set of biological
samples plasma samples from
patients with different immune scape
mutations and hbsag quantification
by liaison murex sa was successful
for all patients
another important biomarker
for the management of patients with the
chronic hbv
infection is represented by
hbeag we know that
positivity to hbehg
is indicative of high levels of a viral
replication
and usually hbeag is
positive during the first two phases of
a chronic hbv
infection during the natural
course the natural history of a chronic
hbv infection
as we have seen before the loss
of hbeag is considered
a favorable prognostic marker
indeed different studies have shown that
hbeag loss implying the entry into the
hbeag
negative chronic infection is associated
with
a reduced risk to develop
cirrhosis or hepatocellular carcinoma
and it is also associated with
a higher probability to achieve hbscg
loss
and as hbv functional
cure similarly in
hbehg positive patients
receiving treatment hbeag
loss is an important therapeutic
endpoint
that has been associated with
long-lasting
therapeutic response and also with
clinical
improvement beyond
the qualitative detection of
hbeag so far there are essays allowing
hb eag quantification
and the different studies have
evaluated the role of quantitative
hb ehg in predicting
hbeag loss during treatment
in particular this study has shown that
a one long decrease in hbeag
levels at week 12 of
treatment can help identifying
patients more prone to achieve
undetectable
serum hbv dna and also
more prone to achieve hb eag
loss similarly this study
led in hiv plus hbv
co-infected patients shows that
a specific combination of quantitative
hbsag
and quantitative hbehg
can again help identifying patients
with a higher probability to achieve
hbeag loss
at this time i would like to share with
you
our experience on the quantification of
hbeag in particular we quantify
different samples by using the liaison
sa for hb
eag quantification by using
serial dilution we found that dsa
shows a very high linearity and a very
high
reproducibility we quantify the hbeag
levels in different phases of hbv
infection in particular in the setting
of
acute infection in patients with
hbeag positive chronic infection
h-b-e-a-g-positive chronic hepatitis
and also in the setting of hbv
reactivation the highest
levels of hbeag
were observed in patients with acute
infection
and in patients with hbv reactivation
indeed in these two settings viral
replication
is particularly high conversely
the lowest levels were observed in
patients with
hbeag chronic hepatitis
indeed this phase is characterized by
a stronger immune response against
the virus that can control hbeag
production and more in general viral
replication
interestingly we observed a positive
correlation between hbeag levels
and hbsag levels
in all group of patients analyzed
conversely in acute infection
and in patients with hbeag
positive chronic hepatitis we found a
negative
correlation between hbeag
levels and alt and
transaminases again this result
can be explained can support
the modulation in hbeag production
by the immune system
finally we focus the attention on
patients with hbv reactivation
who started an antiviral therapy for
more than 12
months in this group of patients
alt normalization was observed in the
vast majority of them
hbeag loss was observing 50 percent of
patients
and undetectable serum hbv dna
in 60 of patients
interestingly we identified a specific
combination of quantitative hbsag
and quantitative hbehg
that can help identifying a patients
more prone to achieve hbeag loss
during treatment again highlighting the
importance to
integrate biological parameters
for an optimized management of the
patients with hpv
infection also in the setting of immune
suppression so in conclusion the
huge distribution of hbv infection
and its pathogenetic
potential strongly support
the importance for a proper hbv
screening
and monitoring and this is a crucial
for a timely identification
of patients who are at higher risk of
disease progression
and those who need to start an antiviral
treatment quantitative hbsag
plays an important role for a proper
staging
of patients and to predict the risk
of liver cancer particularly in the
setting of
hbeag negative patients it
is also important to monitor
treatment response particularly to
interferon
alpha and we should remember the
importance of the assays
targeting multiple hbsag epitopes
to overcome the issue of immune escape
mutations so far the quantification of
hbeag
is feasible in clinical practice
hbeag levels vary during the different
phases of hbv infection and
according to the literature quantitative
hbeag
can play a role in identifying patients
more prone to achieve the hbeag
loss that is as we have seen before
an important and favorable outcome
in during the natural history of a
chronic hbv
infection finally the integration
of biological biomarker is pivotal
for an optimized management of patients
with hbv infection and
i thank you for the attention
and thank you dr speaker for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many as we have time for
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions
coming in from our audience dr speaker
in patients with hbe ag negative
chronic infection is there a threshold
of hb sag that can
predict the loss
thank you for these uh for this question
in hbea g negative a chronic
infection the rate of
hbsh loss increases
by by age and it has been estimated to
be
around 3 percent per year
in individuals older than 50
years previous studies
have shown that in this setting of
patients an hbsag less than 100
international units per ml can
help identifying patients more prone to
achieve
hbsag laws so this means
that an hbscg less than 100
international unit per ml that
can reflect a limited intraopathic
reservoir
can help identifying patients with a
higher probability to achieve
hbv functional cure furthermore
it has been also shown that an hbsg
less than 100 international unit per ml
is usually preceded by a decline
a strong decline in hbscg levels
presumably driven by an
inactivation of immune response
thank you so much dr speaker our next
question is
is there a role of quantitative hbsag
in predicting the risk of vertical
transmission
thank you so much for this interesting
question vertical
transmission of hbv infection is an
important topic
responsible for the larger distribution
of hbv infection
in a different region worldwide
according to the easel guidelines an
hbseg
higher than four log international
unit per ml can help identifying
mothers who have an higher probability
to transmit
the virus to their newborns and so this
threshold of hbsag can
help identify mothers who need
to start an antiviral treatment in order
to reduce the risk for hbv
vertical transmission and eventually to
reduce
the amount of the transmitted virus
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions
coming in dr speaker why
are hbs ag levels more stable
in hbeag negative patients than
in h-b-e-a-g positive ones
thank you this is another interesting
question
and the answer is related to the
capability
of hbv to integrate its
dna we have seen before that
hbv can integrate the portions of its
dna
into the epastocytes genome
this event has been
linked to hepatocarcinogenesis indeed it
is considered
an important mechanism underlying hbv
potential however hbv dna
integration can also be a source
for the production of viral
proteins it has been estimated that
the rate of hbv dna integration
is higher in hbeag negative
patients and in particular in these
patients hbv dna integration
can represent a source for the
production
of hbsag so hbscg
can derive either from ccc dna
and either from integrated hbv
dna and this is responsible for the
stability
of hbscg levels observed during
treatment
thank you so much dr speaker we have
time for one more question
our audience member asks which is the
prevalence of
immune escape mutations in hbv
genotypes other than d
again thank you for these questions we
have seen before that
uh some immunoscape mutations can be
constitutively found
in hbv genotypes other than
d however immune escape mutations can be
also generated
during the during viral
replication even if the prevalence of
the patients
with at least one immune escape
mutations is lower in
hbv genotypes other than d
in particular overall a genotype d is
characterized by a higher degree of
genetic
variability indeed it is characterized
by
a faster accumulation of immune escape
mutations also other mutations in the
basal core promoter and
presumably this higher degree of
genetic variability can be explained
by a stronger immune
response against this genotype
thank you so much for your time today dr
speaker and your presentation
would you like to provide any closing
remarks for our audience before we go
oh i i just would like
to stress that that it has been a great
pleasure for me today to talk about
the importance of a proper diagnosis
a proper monitoring of hbv indeed
despite the availability of a vaccine
despite the availability of potent
drugs against this virus hbv
still represents an important
cause of morbidity and mortality
and a proper hbv diagnosis a proper
monitoring is crucial to
optimize the management of patients
to identify patients at risk of disease
progression
and to start a a treatment an antiviral
treatment dr speaker it's been an honor
thank you again for your time and your
important research
and i also want to take the moment to
thank lab roots and our sponsor
dia soren for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go thank you to the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions
and as a reminder questions we do not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share this email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time stay safe
stay healthy
take care bye everyone